it's been really sad the last like two
weeks leading up to our last day have
been very emotional we've been seeing by
two cast members and clones and every
day there's been somebody leaving and
that was a yeah it was really sad I'm
kind of in shock still that it's done
two days ago Tatiana maslany tweeted out
the words no clone Club member wanted to
hear
Obi wrapped this year's nine times CSA
winner was officially done but the
friendships will last forever
we're just such close friends and we all
love each other very much and as scene
partners they're all incredible and as
you know collaborators and his friends
it's just it's just been a really
special show this girl looks nothing
like me of course
Tatiana played clone after clone on the
series but if the cast had their way
which Canadian would they love to see
doubles up Alanis Morissette I think
that's the twelve-year-old in me
speaking I'm a big fan of Wendy Crewson
who Joni Mitchell
you know what clone like it's the most
ultimate Canadian thing ever I would
clone Wayne Gretzky